September 22nd 2000 Anaheim
California it's another magical day at
the happiest place on Earth
[Music]
Disneyland four-year-old Brandon Tucker
and his family arrive at the famous
theme park to celebrate his mother's
birthday everyone is excited for the fun
awaiting them and as always the magic of
Disneyland does not disappoints the
Zucker spent the whole day exploring the
park and having a blast but just as they
were about to leave decided to hop on
one last ride the Roger Rabbit cartoon
[Music]
spin it seemed like the perfect way to
end their Disneyland Adventure so when
they reached the front of the line
Brandon his older brother and his mom
got into one of the cartoonish cars
while his father and grandmother got
into the one behind them soon the r
started chugging down the tracks the
boys were obviously excited for the cars
to start spinning but as soon as they
did start spinning everything went
horribly
wrong for some reason the force of the
spinning cart threw little Brennon from
the vehicle and he fell straight onto
the track where the other cars were
quickly approaching it all happened so
fast that there was no time to stop the
ride and within seconds the next car
carrying his dad and his grandma pinned
Brandon to the tracks with his body
folded forward at the waist and the full
weight of the car pushing into his back
Brandon was dragged a full 10 ft before
the ride was forced to stop but the
horror didn't end there it took a whole
10 minutes for staff to get him out from
under the car and by then the damage had
already been done Brandon had already
gone several minutes without a pulse or
breathing in that time he suffered
severe brain damage and even though he
survived the accident for a while he was
never able to fully recover he never
walked or spoke again Brandon lived out
the rest of his life in a long-term care
facility for kids with brain injuries
until he passed away in his mother's
arms 8 years after the tragic accidents
all because his family wanted to take a
trip to Disneyland after a detailed
investigation by the state division of
occupational safety and health They
concluded that the Disneyland employees
did not put Brandon into the ride
properly since he was so small he was
supposed to be the furthest one from the
entryway of the car but instead he was
positioned right next to it plus they
didn't even fully lower the lap bar to
keep Brandon strapped in the state
ordered Disneyland to make big changes
to the ride safety procedures including
putting in sensor equipment below each
car to automatically stop them if
anything goes wrong but the thing about
Brandon zucker's horrible accident at
Disneyland that day is that it wasn't
just some onetime fluke this wasn't just
an extremely unlucky accident it was all
part of a terrifying Trend in the Years
leaning up to Brandon's tragedy there
were way more accidents than usual
happening at the park which was crazy
because Disneyland was expected to be
the standard for theme park safety it
had always been considered the most
secure theme park in the country people
trusted Disneyland because they went
above and beyond to keep their kids safe
so what happened why had the happiest
place on Earth suddenly become a bright
and shiny death trap well as it turns
out most of these accidents are soon
after Disneyland HED the most powerful
the most influential the most ruthless
consulting company out there a
consulting company called McKenzie you
may remember McKenzie from when they
pushed Purdue farmer to sling oxycotton
to the masses causing the opioid
epidemic or when Mackenzie offered
Consulting to Enron Enron was created by
an ex McKenzie employee yes this is the
consulting company that Disneyland hired
and it's a stark reminder of what
happens when you make a deal with the
devil this video is based on the book
when Mackenzie comes to town which goes
into all the evil all the tragedy all
the suffering that happens when McKenzie
comes to town we'll link to the book
below so stay dangerous subscribe for
more and this is exactly what happens
when McKenzie comes to
[Music]
Disneyland and really fast guys if you
want to get something for yourself or a
loved one that no one else is going to
have then you got to check out Holtz
curtain Holtz curtain makes these super
unique wooden watches and natural
jewelry that no one else is going to
have one of the problems of shopping for
me is that I hate wearing stuff other
people have that's why I really
appreciate Holk because their stuff is
truly unique and with Valentine's Day
just around the corner they have plenty
of products that make great gifts like
these beautiful earrings that I got my
girlfriend they're plated in real gold
and she loves them and this super unique
purse is made out of real Stone on the
outside and genuine Italian leather on
the inside while still being very light
she loves nature so these were perfect
for her and I got myself this watch that
made out of real dark maple wood very
pretty it's got a solar movement it's
got a swappable bezel while not breaking
the bank and all this stuff comes with a
24mon warranty and a 24-day money back
guarantee H scor is giving my viewers
15% off so you can find the perfect gift
that's really going to stand out just go
to hr.com jran to get 15% off your
purchase with promo code jake5 that's
hr.com jran for 15% off with code
jake5 by the 1990s Disneyland had been
opened for more than four decades and
had become the most famous theme park in
America every year millions of visitors
from all over the world came to
experience the magic and joy of
Disneyland and the park was turning a
mass of profits but then in 1994 things
started changing that year Disneyland
got a new top executive named Paul
presler Paul thought that it was time to
make even more money it was time to
squeeze every last penny out of the park
as possible and so he decided to hire
the best guys out there to help McKenzie
and Company Mckenzie was founded back in
1926 and since then they' become the
most powerful the most influential
consulting firm on the planet and what
exactly is this big thing called
Consulting well it's actually very
simple corporations want to make more
profit so they hire Mackenzie to tell
them what to do to make more money and
shockingly it works Mackenzie has a
track record of making their clients
very very rich no matter the cost and
that is why McKenzie has been able to
sink their teeth into everyone from
trillion dollar companies like Microsoft
to government entities like the US
Department of energy which is
responsible for America's nukes and so
Paul presser thought who better than
Mackenzie to make Disneyland more
profitable and they signed the contract
and McKenzie proceeded to keep a close
eye on the operations of Disneyland for
over a year after that year passed by
McKenzie came back to Paul with a plan
for how the park could bring in more
money than ever before and their plan
could not have been more genius see a
really big expense for theme parks like
Disneyland is maintenance making sure
the rides are well maintained and safe
for visitors the problem was Disneyland
was putting their most experienced
employees who had the most knowledge
about the rides in charge of keeping the
ride safe which was costing them a lot
of money see your employees cost a lot
of money and so McKenzie's
recommendation was simple Disneyland
should use a technique called
reliability centered maintenance it was
a cool sounding strategy it sounded all
Technical and fancy it was based on a
legit procedure originally used by the
aviation industry to track maintenance
histories over time but in reality for
Disneyland it was all about saving money
on these expensive maintenance costs
according to McKenzie all Disneyland
needed to do was fire these expensive
experienced employees and hire less
knowledgeable outside contractors who
charge way less less maintenance cost
more money simple but obviously it
wouldn't be a good look for Disneyland
to just fire these experienced employees
responsible for keeping everyone safe
but McKenzie had it all thought out for
their clients the first step was
transferring all of Disneyland's
maintenance workers to the overnet
graveyard shift then Disneyland could
keep a much smaller less experienced
group that would handle mechanical
breakdowns of R during the day but lots
of people didn't agree with these
changes a former maintenance supervisor
at the park said there's nothing wrong
with saving money but not at the expense
of your Prime objective which is to keep
the place running safely but according
to McKenzie that made no logical sense
why should Disney keep paying people to
check rides every day if none of them
were breaking down one employee who
worked at Disneyland for 20 years put it
plainly the reason they don't fail is
because we chck them every night but
Disneyland didn't listen they were
already on the hook for the giant Bill
Mackenzie was invoicing them so they
followed MacKenzie's advice they fell
for that consistency bias where you want
to keep doing things you already
committed to even if it's stupid and by
1997 there was a major cultural Shi that
focused on economics being as lean an
operation as possible to maximize profit
at Disneyland the message was do more
with less and the results were
[Music]
deadly
Christmas Eve 1998 10:40 a.m. a man
named Lan Dawson his wife and their son
were enjoying their morning at
Disneyland when they decided to get on a
ride called the Columbia a vintage 84t
ship that runs on an underwater track
docking a ship of this size requires
special training but on this particular
day a supervisor with no experience
filled in for an employee that was out
sick as the boat was hurling towards the
dock she tied a rope to the middle hitch
on the boats but she did it way too soon
the power of the moving vessel tore the
metal piece loose which was
unfortunately connected to a chunk of
rotting wood the boat speed meant that
that chunk of wood and metal shattered
with the force of an exploding bomb
sending fragments of the breeze flying
through the air the debris hit Luan
Dawson first killing him instantly his
wife who was sitting next to him was
also severely disfigured from the blast
and it all happened right in front of
their young son the incident brought a
lot of negative attention to Disneyland
the Dawson family's L insisted that the
accident happened because of
Disneyland's cost efforts at the
advice of McKenzie he said that
Disneyland have fired all their r leads
who were the highly paid safety experts
that were assigned to each ride this
included the ride for the Columbia not
to mention all the experienced
maintenance workers who have been switch
over to the overnight shift so none of
them were around to help with problems
throughout the day Disneyland knew or
should have known that making extensive
cutbacks in safety and maintenance
programs would ultimately have
devastating effects on the safety of the
public the family's lawyer said but
still Disneyland refused to listen and
so that incident became the first of
many it had barely been a year and
Disneyland had already claimed his first
life after McKenzie came to
[Music]
a little over a year later the Space
Mountain roller coaster one of the park
most popular rides was taking a spin
when one of his wheels suddenly got
dislodged from the track this jolted the
ride to a sudden Halt and badly injured
nine passengers in the process when an
investigation into the accident was
conducted they found what do you know
poor maintenance to be the cause it was
only a couple of months earlier when
Brandon Zucker happened crushed out the
other ride and even though the parks
swore that they clean up their acts
after so much tragedy in such a short
time the accidents kept coming summer
2003 Disneyland employees report a weird
clicking noise coming from the Big
Thunder Mountain roller coaster even
after mechanics tried to fix the issue
the clicking noise continued a note was
put down that the roller coaster
shouldn't be used until they figured out
the issue but it was used anyways so on
September 5th 22-year-old Marcelo tus
and his friends got on the ride
completely oblivious to his history of
mechanical problems the train R departed
and just as it went around a curve the a
rod broke the piece wedged itself
between the track and the ride pushing
the first car over and crushing Marcelo
Torres to death 10 other Riders were
injured as well when the state looked
into the accident they found that once
again it was due to poor maintenance and
employee training issues it was obvious
that Disneyland was falling apart and
his parkourers were paying the ultimate
price but who could be responsible well
there was one thing connecting all these
fatal accidents McKenzie and Company but
do you think McKenzie took
responsibility for these acents or got
punished in any way nope the Disney
corpor option is still working with
MacKenzie as late as
2022 before making this video I actually
talked to an ex Disneyland employee and
she told me about all the measures they
take to make sure no one sees anything
bad happening at the happiest place on
Earth if a visitor is absolutely wasted
or if someone has a medical emergency or
is too rowdy there are hidden Pathways
alongside all the common areas with
hidden doors where Disneyland Security
will grab the person and take them out
of sight as fast as possible so nothing
corrupts the other visitors impression
of Disneyland so if they're that
maniacal about maintaining their Perfect
Image it's no surprise that today no one
even knows or remembers these brutal
deaths in accidents Disneyland has
managed to completely erase his dark
history of deaths and injuries in the
park so what if they accidentally killed
a bunch of people in the name of saving
a dime who can stay mad at the happiest
place on Earth and as for Mackenzie they
never face any repercussions for
providing this advice that led to these
deaths nobody ever looked twice at
McKenzie and that is Mackenzie specialty
they offer advice that ruins the lives
of millions and they always walk away
Scott free every single time you see
Disneyland wasn't the only business that
McKenzie turned into a death trap for
profits nope just look at what happened
when McKenzie consulted ice the
Immigration and Customs enforcements
Mckenzie was brought in to help them
figure out how to save money on illegal
immigration and MacKenzie's
recommendations were so cruel and
inhumane that they even made ice workers
feel uncomfortable McKenzie suggested
that the government agency should cut
their spending on food and medical care
for detainees they should just scale
about the amount of food and medical
care they provide just like they did
with r mainus at Disneyland and it's
just as disturbing as you can imagine
and we're going to cover in a future
video in this new series we're doing on
McKenzie but you want to know who else
keeps getting away with it Will
Smith see on the surface Will Smith has
done a great job at marketing himself as
a super good genuine guy but underneath
the surface he has a very dark side to
him and one of the things that Jada has
over him will lost it and beat the sh
Jada and and that's when I see Dwayne
and having anal sex with will let me
process that for a
second who was on top so at the time uh
Charlie the rat Mack was kind of his
bodyguard you know and uh you know will
gave him a nod and Charlie hit this guy
so hard like blood gushed out his eye
and we uncover it all in our new
documentary on our other channel how to
get away with it that you can watch
right now by clicking the card on the
screen click the card on the screen to
watch this juicy documentary
[Music]
now